[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
what's going on guys i'm pretty sure you
hear me i don't know it says you hear me
but obs be bugging sometimes so put a
one in the chat and hear me a two in the
chat you hear me or three for me to shut
up the podcast you don't want to hear me
what happened to the attic show where we
talk about the past
present future gaming i don't have my
co-host with me today he he he he he is
incapacitated i don't know what's going
on with him uh shout out to hoss i hope
you feel better man but i got dirt
griggity with me man i got dirt griggy
with me what's going on dirk what's up
bro how you doing man
how do i sound is my levels okay you
sound good to me
all right what's happening bro i'm doing
pretty good man uh you know it's uh we
we got a pretty crazy show you know
what's funnies i literally i almost
cancelled the show man because you know
i'm sitting i woke up i'm at my girl's
house because i've been over there the
past couple days because i'm having a
lot of like
uh you know stuff going on at my work uh
drop a place like uh you know uh i won't
go too much into that but
so you know i'm sitting here dealing
with all that so i'm like i got to go
i gotta go like i gotta get out of my
house because i don't know why like
maybe this is my problem but like when i
feel when i'm here at my house let's go
ahead and move that there well when i'm
here at my house i always feel like i
got to do something you know what i'm
saying like because i got the setup like
i should be making videos i should be
making tick tocks i should i should be
making doing something why am i watching
stranger things
right but if i'm away from it i feel
like i'm good like even if i wanted to
it's not here
so you know
going all through this i wake up and i'm
like you know what do i really want to
drive 30 minutes home to do this podcast
and then i and then i was sitting there
i'm like you know what i kind of want to
talk so yeah so
my uh i drove 30 minutes home to do this
podcast and i'm driving right back to
her house but you know it is what it is
it's not that bad no like 30 minutes
isn't bad at all yeah but see
you guys have these ridiculous like hour
and a half to two hour commutes that you
guys do and out in like you know i i
remember kiss me used to drive like an
hour and a half to two every day to work
and i'm like oh damn not me
no no
damn that's a lot that is a lot hour and
a half goodness yeah so you know
appreciate ever coming through though
you know we're gonna have a good show we
got some good topics for you guys yeah
let let me bring the topics up real
quick yeah we got the play impressions
man we got the take two remarks on game
pass because apparently everyone got a
comment on dang dangerous on game pass
but we're going to talk about that we
got xbox selling great and wanting
everyone and now we got people out there
mooch i'm going to just say your name
mooch oh hey say your name mooch we got
people like uh mooch you know no shade
much knows his family but he knows when
when i got something to get across i'ma
use his name because there you go when
you go on what's funny is people are
writing articles about this and i
understand where much is coming from but
at the same time i'm like dude it is
what it is you know we'll start with
that let's start with that normally i
ask you
but you've been on here a couple times
so i'm choosing today
all right go go for what you know my
brother all right so
have you seen that xbox is those npd's
or those worldwide cells cause these
japan on there and i see the uk on there
that's worldwide for the last week yeah
the worldwide yeah
it's crazy okay first off this
what's been going on is
last generation a lot of the times every
month it was two to one two to one
sometimes that's three one
the fact that
uh
look look uh see that that's my girl
right there or
i uh i can't ask acg to come on the
podcast last minute the the man's busy
all right like i get it hustle ain't
here but we will get him up here
in a different day
i'm sure he's working on like eight
reviews right now because that man don't
sleep so
let him work babe let him work but
anyway so xbox has been winning these
these these monthly sell well these
weekly sales right but when you start
adding you know you one two two weeks
here three weeks here it's a day and
month after time so like look
is it anything to say no but i will say
that it's interesting that you go from
a a series such as that's what i'm
looking for
you go from situations last gen
and you go from the point that last gen
was
dir is it fair to say that
they have no business being winning any
of these months how do you go from one
of the worst generations you've ever had
and to some point
where
it's over like you what i'm saying like
you don't recover from that and
and it's it's an interesting thing and i
think it's interesting just because
it shows that
the
what's the word i'm looking for
the perception of microsoft and xbox
is at a completely different level than
it used to be absolutely bro
absolutely how do you do that
yes i think you just explained it like
the perception is completely different
than last generation you know if like
you know i see a lot of people that rock
out with my channel
rock out with my podcast in the chat and
these guys know what i'm about to say
because i say it a lot about last
generation um
xbox you know wasn't great last
generation and like you said they were
being outsold 2-1
3-1 you know they got their teeth kicked
in
to see what's happening now i remember
cognito said
every generation is completely different
right and the perception of xbox has
changed
whether it's
you know the the
the acquisition of zenimax whether it
was the acquisition of activision
blizzard or maybe it's just
the xbox series s or maybe it says word
of mouth about game pass
all of those things are absolutely
positive because
attic they're doing this they are
selling great without any damn first
party games
like i know halo dropped last year
but here we are six months into 2022
they haven't had any first party games
and the systems are selling great
what is it
i think it's all of those things i think
it's a combination all of those things
i think a lot of it like look like
people say oh it's because they bought
activision it's because they bought
bethesda i don't think that is like i do
think that there are a certain amount of
casual consumers that pay attention to
big stuff like that
but i don't think it's like as big as
people think i think that's a small
percentage of people i think people are
buying series s's and series x is
probably mainly series s's because of
the value it brings to them because you
can go in there
it's like you know bg i know a lot of
people got issues with bg but
it's it is literally at that very high
point of an impulse buy 300 is a lot of
money to a lot of people but it's not a
lot of money to a lot of people where
it's like one of those things where it's
not more than a tv a a decent nice tv
and it's not less where you feel like
it's it's the quality of that product's
bad
so that that's the biggest thing i think
yeah i agree but see well
the reason i said the activism blizzard
announcement the zenimax announcement
yes most casuals don't know about that
but
i had a story where a friend of mine who
was extreme casual the only thing this
guy plays is 2k and
warzone call of duty war zone
and he called me
a couple days after xbox announced it
and he said yo dirk is it true that xbox
just bought
call of duty like he didn't even know
activists he said is it true today this
bought call of duty
i said yeah yeah that's true man um any
and like the next question he asked me
was does that mean that the call of duty
games is going to be in game pass and i
said most likely now like i said this is
a good friend of mine but he's a super
casual and he somehow knew about it but
i bet you i understand what you're
saying
here probably but i understand what you
said it's a small percentage and you're
absolutely right but at the end of the
day the xbox series s is that console
like you said it's imposed by like or
even people you know i can't get x okay
you know let me get the s and it's uh
it's technically a next generation
console and that price man it's hard to
pass
it's a good price man so all right with
all this selling going on you know
they've been selling pretty good like i
said the fact that they are out selling
playstation on any level is is is
amazing because last generation they
were at a position where it was
debatable they would ever do any better
and now absolutely they are you know
theoretically they could potentially win
months in the world we're not talking
about just
the northern continent we're not talking
about just canada mexico in the uh north
america we're talking about the world
and that they're doing better on that we
have situations where they have sold
more than the playstation 5 in their own
region
yeah that's crazy sure i think that's a
little i think they're a little blown
ahead proportion that's just me yeah you
know yeah
but we got to see if that kind of energy
stays forward going forward uh but i
will say
that
microsoft i do feel like sure they have
a long way to go they have a long way to
go but i do think that with their
two-prong approach
where we're gonna get you with the
cheapest and the most uh the cheapest
the strongest
approach and we're gonna have this
this battery known as game pass fueling
both of those those exactly we're going
to hit you on both areas i think
that has really helped them evolve to
where they are now now keep in mind
this is also a scenario where
you know
i honestly feel like game pass hasn't
really delivered this year it's been
very lackluster sure there's games that
appeal to some people but as far as
their first party they haven't really
dropped a whole lot and they're still
bodying competition
week to week half the time and we're not
talking like
we're talking outselling playstation in
the states by like half by like double
people could say look two to one we know
that a lot of it has to do with
the lack of supply on playstation we
know that of course but at the same time
it's like david jaffe said on the iop
the couple weeks ago
sony could have did that same deal that
microsoft did but they didn't pull the
trigger so at the end of the day whose
fault is that is it microsoft's fault
for using their money wisely to make
sure they get the actual stock out there
or is it sony's fault for not using that
money i'm not going to say that you know
this is going to happen going out but
you know i want to ask you dirt real
quick because it's just me and you we
can little we can wing it a little bit
but i want to ask you
is it fair to say that the beginning of
a generation is the worst time to not be
able to meet demand
uh yeah
i think so because my personal opinion
is if we have this kind of scenario go
on
and
you can't meet the man let's say i got
five friends all right let's say i got
five friends
two of those people they they buy in
early they only get xbox if they get an
xbox hell my girlfriend wanted a
playstation five i was like we ain't
gonna find one
so guess what she has right now dirt
what's that she got an xbox series x wow
so look it happens a lot and like look
didn't look sure you know i guess you
guys can arguably say that i convinced
her to get a series x and i didn't i
really didn't i said if you want a
playstation you'll have to look for one
i don't know if you can get one but she
said i'm not waiting i want a console
now so she got an xbox now let's say
she's one of those people and someone
else gets an xbox kick they can't let's
say the other three upgrade in a couple
years
let's say we're all friend group where
you think those other three are going to
go dirt
well their friends have
xboxes they're probably going to get
xbox also you're absolutely right
now i will say stuff like cross plays
made it easier to play where you want to
play
but just because there's cross play
doesn't mean there's cross party systems
there's no discord connecting all these
platforms together when i was playing
destiny
and
when i did play warzone i'd use the
whack
part game chats
game chat isn't really something that
you could rely on when it comes to stuff
like that
so
it's best if you are going now it's
different if you have like one person
over there yeah you could play cross
play you guys i have to go to all the
game chat but the majority of you are
using party chat for the majority of
these gaming sessions but when you're
constantly using game chat i feel like
i'm about to go deaf because i can't
hear this person this person sounds too
quiet this person's eating his mic i
don't know what's going on background
noise with this other person and not to
mention you know they they got that
weird playstation thing you know the one
that you talk you you're talking to i
don't have a controller with me here
the playstation controller that's got
the mic on the bottom yeah
i have heard that in game chat and that
is annoying but i will say
it is actually a lot better than i
originally was going to give it props
i thought that was gonna be dog [ __ ]
i thought that was gonna be like some of
the i thought you was gonna hear people
arguing in the background because you're
gonna know that shit's on right i'm sure
if you
if if you're playing your friend's
system when he's at work or something
and you pick up that control man i'm
sure people get caught cheating with
this thing
get the the boyfriend comes over plays
the the the boyfriend comes over and
plays the plays the husband's
playstation why the wife's cooking
dinner oh god why is this thing on
exactly it's just like you know i do
think that when it comes to that this is
the worst night does that mean they're
going to win the generation no no of
course not but this is you go when you
when you time that they're winning
without the games and they're winning
with because they have the supply
what's going to happen when they have
the supply and the games that's that's a
very good question because
i think that's a
that's a question we have to ask because
like you say if they're doing this with
literally zero first party games in 2022
when that
as pong soul said that avalanche of
games start to drop
what's going to happen then if they're
going to drop a triple a game every what
three or four months once like what like
maybe starfield comes out then maybe red
fall one then hell blade and then then
you know all of these games coming out
like they're going to have a steady flow
and that's going to be something that
you know that's a good question man
what's going to happen then i don't see
it dropping off
people maybe it will increase i think
all of a sudden they're going to start
losing money at that point
it's like the beginning of the
playstation they didn't re the the ps4
generation they didn't have a whole lot
of games you know they had good indies
they had a couple good games but they
have anything serious i personally felt
like once bloodborne hit
that's when the official spirit bomb
done hit microsoft straight in the face
because after that game every holiday
every year was just more and more good
[ __ ] like then yeah i don't know when
persona came up but you know personally
like it's just there was so much last
year and microsoft had that little bit
of window in the beginning to get stuff
together
and they got a little bit of stuff but
it wasn't nearly as much as they needed
to hold that whole generation down when
the playstation was going
see see added with that perception of
xbox the first few years like you said
xbox i think the first few years of xbox
one generation they had better software
i know playstation had a couple of good
games uh you know like infamous second
son they had
like you said bloodborne job to 2015.
you know they had a couple of good games
but xbox had it man they had some great
games from titanfall to their rising
three to sunset overdrive 2014 halo 5
2015. so that first three years xbox had
great software but the perception of
them
wasn't great
ps4 was more powerful
you know and
i
it's like everybody turned against xbox
the beginning of the xbox one generation
and they was not able to recover because
by the time sony started dropping their
great games
xbox wasn't dropping any games yo i'm
sorry i gotta interrupt you real quick
oh no you're good this johnny depp and
amber heard thing is over officially and
i think that woman is never getting a
job like she's never working ever again
look she's become a meme someone said
amber heard likes playstation yeah i saw
that trayvon yeah that's like look like
i ain't saying the woman don't deserve
to ever work
but if you hire her at this age with
tick-tock against her
twitter against her oh man uh people are
already saying i myself ain't gonna go
watch the next pirates of the caribbean
because and it has nothing to do with
him not being uh with with you know the
court case or anything going on i just
personally feel like that movie doesn't
make sense without him
yeah you can't do that movie without him
bro you can't do that you can't replace
captain jack sparrow about him but that
that's he is captain jax bro he doesn't
know there's no other no you can't do
that movie without him bro i think that
is probably the character in
tv and movie history that you could
never replace like people want to say
like iron man you can't you could
replace iron man sure people ain't gonna
like it
uh but there are characters
that that's them like you see them like
uh the person who played harry potter i
don't think you could ever replace him
like there's just certain people you
know you know those people are those are
the people that years can go by and you
still see them as that original
character
yeah yeah every time i see sylvester
stallone he's still rocky to me
yeah well you know rocky
anyway we'll go ahead we'll uh you know
move on from that conversation i didn't
want to go so let's talk about the real
reason i brought this up and it's
you know what it is man
it's spicy
that's some spicy noodles i like spicy
man i like spicy
uh so
there's a lot of people and you know
i'll go ahead and uh you know like i
said i brought up much earlier um i
brought up what we'll do is i will find
the tweet
and this is what pretty much happened
so
they
uh for those who don't know xbox 448
posted the hardware [ __ ] chart for 20 uh
for 21 str uh for the 21st
that week may of 2022
and here is the
which you know i could probably share it
to you guys
i guess
you know what you got you i will send it
to you in the chat we ain't doing all
that because then i have to restructure
everything we do none of that all right
so pretty much what he said is he just
showed all the
the actual
stuff
and then what happened is he said let me
find he said i need an explanation here
if people buy consoles on those triple a
quote unquote bangers and xbox hasn't
released a first party game this year
how are they moving so
many units
right i think that's a valuable question
like yeah absolutely so in
um
it looks like the northern part of the
world uh they sold 69 000 that's funny
they had that
six nine nine six nine that is crazy
so then uh playstation so thirty four
thousand i'm willing to bet that that is
strictly because of uh you know they
can't make enough units right it looks
like you know uh other places in the
world uh they sold seven thousand i
wonder
is that what is that
is that two weeks they've sold that kind
of numbers in japan that's two yeah man
because last week they uh well like two
weeks ago they show stole like six
thousand and some change
i was amazed by that oh wow
see now i gotta hear king now i gotta
hear king
now you know what's funny don't have it
let me say this right quick before you
go remember like like there was
sometimes in the xbox one generation
they would sell like
six
in a week in japan like literally six or
seven
so to see them sell like six seven
thousand two weeks in a row was pretty
impressive over there
now i gotta hear king now i gotta hear
king he gonna talk about that all right
and then uh you know
at the end of it all worldwide
one 131 to 123 not a big difference oh
it's not but we're talking worldwide and
we're talking this is like what two
weeks of this
last week it was like 60 70 000. yeah
like look like i'm not saying that
this like i said i'm sure that if the
playstation thing here i don't think
people
people want me to believe dirk that if
playstation had enough units in every
game stop walmart target best buy that
there would be like
like
like like literally like we don't even
need these numbers people want me to
believe that instead of that 123 there's
like an infinity m symbol like they sold
everything like that
look i'm not gonna say that if they had
stalk they wouldn't sell more than play
xbox because i'm pretty sure they would
yeah but we're not going to see her and
act like they would sell them by three
or four times the amount they want you
to act like they're going to sell like
five or six million a month
they would prob they would probably
double those numbers maybe yeah maybe
maybe because people need to realize
just because it's hot don't mean people
got the money to buy exactly especially
when you have to buy it in a in a bundle
yeah i know how i had to buy mine
yeah the bundle man i was like come on
brother
so
now let's let's talk about
mooch where mooch comes in this so mr
carmen has said xbox series s is why
275 price point not a shortage like the
xbox series x and
ps5 the chip shortage doesn't affect the
xbox series s
um okay first off i need numbers mooch
where this doesn't affect the series s i
know it doesn't affect it to a large
amount
uh but
i think
how is everything getting a shortage but
just that console i guess the because to
my knowledge
the entire tech industry is is a huge
shortage yeah uh so look i'm i'm i'm
gonna be with you there mooch they're
selling that much because of the s but i
don't think they're making like eight
times the amount that the x is they
probably make two to three times the
amount i don't think it's like an absurd
amount they make enough to sit on the
shelves from time to time you know
what's funny people are going to a
walmart
and they'll see like a bunch of s's on
the shelf or they'll see like they're on
the part of the shelf that says
pre-ordered or something like that or
already reserved and they'll take a
picture without that top part saying
they're already bought
it's it's crazy it's just like people
look at all these xbox series answers on
the show
it's just like people at black friday
taking pictures of
of like uh pan um what do they call
those things when you're out
a pallet full of xboxes that in
playstations that haven't been able to
be sold yet you know what i'm saying
they're just sitting there like they got
the rap and everything around them and i
saw that i'm like you know they don't
sell stuff with wrap around them they
haven't put it on the floor yet
all right so
then i say as much as i don't like how
some of these games take a little how
some of these games take a little longer
to get that 60 frames patch on the s
series s
i gotta say it it was extremely good for
them to come out with the series s
uh right now we can admit we we
it's so subjective if you want to like
the nitty gritty on the whole generation
we're what maybe two years into it we
still got probably
five to seven years left
so who knows what the series s is going
to look like towards the end of the
generation but right now it's true it's
doing good for them
it is this is where it is th this this
is
this is this is it
mooch
on may the 30th at 2 36 p.m
said i almost think the series s should
be counted separately from the series x
oh some games hitting 540p and some
having a hard time getting 1080p
which is funny because if you think
about he said some getting some games
hitting 540p
and some games having a hard time
getting 1080p doesn't that seem like the
same sentence
yeah if they're not if they're 540p
mooch they're not 1080p
that's i digress smooch
uh it's a nice device but it's it but
it's not applies to
applies to oh it's not apples to apples
okay don't you okay whatever it's not
apples to apples with the xbox series x
and ps5 just my two cents
mitch i love you death man i love you to
death
but we about to talk some [ __ ]
mitch i don't agree with your statement
and you know people feel free to go on
twitter and tag
at
mooch
i don't know his whole thing i think
it's it might be just 78 i think mooch
78 go tag him and tell him kind of pop
up in here and if he gets in here maybe
he'll get him a link i don't know yet it
just depends on if i want him arguing
you know if if if if i wanna you know if
i wanna have a one-way debate i have a
one-way debate it just depends how i
feel once he's in here
uh the reason i don't agree with that is
because like i said there
i feel like
this would be valid criticism
if they didn't
do it in the ps4 and ps4 pro
and the xbox one and the xbox one s and
the xbox one x all three of those
bundles was one thing uh the switch has
like five bundles they're one thing
uh kid smooth uh famously pointed out
that apple has like seven products and
they put it all as one thing do they do
do they separate apple's generations or
is it all still just apple products oh
that's a good question i don't know if
they separate the generations
i don't think you know that's a good
question i can't answer it uh
mooch is a friend i know some of you
don't like mooch uh sometimes i don't
like mooch but he's not a bad dude he's
just got bad takes to me
uh let's stop with the the the attacking
mooch you know you feel free to give him
criticism but let's not be disrespectful
guys mooch is not a bad dude all right
just because you don't agree with them
like i don't agree with them does that
mean we had to attack him as a person
all right but anyway let's get this five
dollar subtract real quick from ray to
blade that ps problem uh that that ps
problem not a xbox problem when ps5 came
the best selling in history xbox is
about to become the fastest comeback in
history
mooch sym i don't know what sym stands
for do you
uh
shut your mouth maybe shut your mouth
yeah okay okay much at your mouth there
you go there you go uh so what do you
feel about this man like
i got it here
well
like you said i don't recall uh
this being brought up last generation be
with the xbox one x and the xbox one s
nobody said that and i think it's pretty
obvious why nobody said that right
because the playstation was kicking
their tv in they were killing xbox last
generation themselves so that never came
up do you recall that coming up at it i
don't i don't remember people saying the
s and uh like the one x and the one s
shouldn't be counted together i don't
call that and that's like you said it's
because it fit a lot of people's
narrative i'm not saying mooch's
narrative on that uh but i am saying
mooch usually is has a has a take that's
a little bit of a pro playstation side
yeah now yeah
i'm sorry let me
let me bring it up i was i was too in my
mooch bag
uh but you know the one thing i want to
say is like look it's like i said if
they would have if they would have
changed that during the xbox one
generation i feel like people would have
criticism now
but i i don't i don't feel like you
could say stuff like that because to a
point it makes no sense
uh we got a
two dollar super chat from ray and
blaine woofer issue is the chip probably
remember bloomberg
um
uh the woofer issue is the chip okay so
yeah it's not the chip itself it's
something you use on the chip i assume
okay and then we got flame with the two
dollar ship uh much uh mooch is mooching
off bad fanboy narratives shake my head
look man
sometimes sometimes
i'm going to say this all right i know a
lot of you people in this jangle like
this
but sometimes it'd be too easy
to
push a chat in the way you want them to
push
way too easy you you can i could easily
see i'm usually a little bit more you
know i'm uh what i like to call a true
neutral like
like i don't i don't
like have a console just so i could talk
[ __ ] about another console like i
literally have both of them and i'll
i've gotten attacked in the same podcast
for asking for starfield to have a
release date and then i get typed by the
same people saying that um i shouldn't
want to play god of war you know what
i'm saying but it is what it is like
look my point is
the fact that these weren't separated
last gen
i feel like no one should have an issue
of how they're doing this gin
uh uh my issue is the switch has never
separated that [ __ ]
so you have really no
point asking for it to be separated now
i agree with you man because like
i've seen well these are two separate
consoles they're
they're big differences in power bro the
xbox one s was way weaker than the xbox
one x the ps4 was weaker than the ps4
pro those guys were two different
consoles
and here we are it's apparently a thing
i always say
if the xbox series wasn't selling well
hypothetically if it wasn't selling well
this narrative would not be a thing
i guarantee this narrative would not be
a thing
i think it's because they're selling
well after everybody said it wouldn't
sell well he said it was a mistake
they said it's holding the next
generation back all of these things that
they said to see that the console was
selling well they got to come up with
another narrative real quick oh separate
them they should be separate so
that's how i look at it yeah it's just
like look like i get it i feel like the
only reason you wouldn't want that you
would want them to be separated
is if you had a narrative you wanted to
go there dude
like
look man
if you watch this later if you watch
this later
just put in the chat or hit me up no put
it in the chat i want you i want you to
to publicly defend yourself okay
put in the chat
why realistically it makes sense to want
them separated because to me
i can't think of one reason that you
would want them separated uh to my
knowledge i i don't i mean mitch might
be an investor but i don't know
i'm willing to i don't think that but he
might be
someone said i have a green screen so i
can't be neutral
oh my god do people not know that green
screens are green for a reason uh
so hold on like so you guys are saying
that his screen should be blue right
like what are you saying
look all i'm saying man is like mooch
man i do feel like a little bit of your
colors came out man the
little playstation colors came out man
you know what i always say about movies
people cannot like much all they want
but man that man can talk
yeah he's like sometimes he's gonna be
talking
[Laughter]
moose has the talent
like the gift for gab man the dude is a
natural
you know he's absolutely natural like he
reminds me like a sports talk show host
man just he's always there with uh like
his analogies you know he's he's really
talented man but you know i don't mean
to always agree with them anymore anyway
yeah it's like i said we we can all
agree on we can all disagree with each
other and still be respectful i feel
like some of you in the chat be a little
wild when sometimes just a little bit
just a little bit but i understand man a
lot of you guys that a lot of you guys
you know i was raising it too uh you
know we were raising very like you know
especially in friend groups where like
our jokes would make people now cry
so absolutely so i i do understand i do
understand that like some of you be
joking but you don't be taken as serious
but it looks like you're taking it
serious because that's how you you talk
in your actual friend group but it is
what it is man but all i'm saying is
like xbox selling great we need to take
advantage of this you know
i i think it's it's good for everyone
that's going to put a playstation to do
more stuff i don't understand this this
this logic that we need to separate them
because because at that point i think
the only person that benefits is
playstation fanboys and playstation uh
you know
i want playstation to be held to the
fire i want that
because
you know maybe i'll get a maybe i'll get
a playstation that i can't commit murder
with you know like maybe you'll actually
be a reasonable size like tell me you
don't look at that thing dirt and think
that you could use that as a blood
object
hey listen man you know my setup i can't
stand it up vertically right i can't do
it do it vertically so i had to put it
on the side it just just looks awkward
man this
it's big it just looks awkward sitting
in there bro my goodness
yeah but it is what it is so you know
we'll move on man we'll move on we'll
move on to
take
two's remarks on gameplay
let me go ahead and get this 10 super
chat from atl appreciate the the the
support man appreciate the support
imagine they made a dongle port of the
series s family they gonna riot
yo imagine you could pay ten dollars for
a dongle port at a walmart and you could
leave there and that's put on that's put
on unit cells for the xbox family
yo yo yo
okay that at that point i think i would
officially is that you dirt in the chat
is that you you or is that someone
actually thank you okay not as me that's
me i'm making you a moderator uh so
i feel like
i at that point i would be a little bit
on the side yo it's 10 bucks man we
can't really put that with this it's not
a console like
right
all right so
first off how do you feel about the
statement because i only read the
headline ain't going to be real i'm
going to be real with you i only run
yeah
i just read the headline also i didn't
need to read the whole article listen
man i i put out a tweet i i quote
tweeted this article
and i said it's easy for him to say
right when you have a game
that sold over 150 million copies
when you uh you know you have like when
you make billions of dollars a year on
whatever shop cards is
you keep on remastering the damn game
you did it three times in nine years
selling it at full price
you're making crazy money on this sad
game not every game sells like that so
yeah it's easy for him to say that
uh you wouldn't make uh like how did he
put it you know you wouldn't make money
in the service i forgot what he said day
one service
obviously he's throwing a shot at game
pass right obviously he's taking a shot
at game pass look man
every game doesn't sell incredible
most games actually don't so incredible
absolutely most games don't sell
incredible most games don't do el nino
ring numbers
most game doesn't do you know spider-man
2018 numbers or god of war numbers or
even halo numbers in the past every game
doesn't do that so if you have a service
and if your company can afford to have a
service
where they can put their games in their
service day one
i think it's benefiting that company
now
i guess maybe
it doesn't benefit them because they
only do like one or two games a year
was that 2k
well
i don't even know that anymore is this
girl like grand theft auto is the
absolute monster
yes that game shouldn't be in the
service that launched probably because
you know that game is going to move
units
150 is number two of all time
yeah so that's easy for him to say at it
yes of course he can say that
but other companies other developers
other games will benefit from a service
like this now us gamers we also benefit
but
to sit there and say that
come on man just stop it he's taking
shots at xbox game pass so if you don't
want to put your game into service you
don't have to but maybe it's benefiting
other companies putting their games in
that service they want
you know what's funny like they have
this energy for this but it's like take
two didn't you have gta in there didn't
you have red dead in there yeah they did
i i mean
for all in a bully could have went in
there i don't know like i mean do they
even really make like i mean 2k's been
in there like what are they saying now
they're there right now day and date
games and i get that like i do to a
point get that
but it's just like
i guess since you only
i don't know man like
part of me understands where they're
coming from but the other part of me
don't like because it's just like
i feel like them in general would be
actually better to have it in a service
don't they have a subscription service
for gta 5 right now
yeah i forgot about that
isn't it something yeah i forgot about
that i forgot the details of it but yeah
there's something they yeah damn yeah i
look that up right quick yeah
flame did make a good point before you
deleted the message uh you know
they don't make a whole lot of games
yearly either and microsoft to this
point right now they don't either
you know microsoft's still catching up
for the pandemic there's still a lot of
issues on why microsoft hasn't released
a lot of games here recently and i think
if you don't have the catalog that's why
microsoft bought so many studios they
don't have the catalog to sustain
something like game pass so i could
understand why he would think that and
to a point you know we can't act like
a gta 5
you can't act like they didn't make that
money they made a lot of money off the
initial sells of that game
but they made a lot of money off shark
cards
way more than they made off selling the
game absolutely so to me
they could easily do that and maybe that
would even encourage more people yo i
did have you ever bought played a game
on game pass or anything or played a
free-to-play game you're like yeah i
didn't put no money into this let me
slow my car a little bit like yeah like
i feel like people do that so absolutely
like i think they would actually make
more money like i don't know but i'm not
encouraging micro transactions okay
let's calm down a little bit but i do
feel like to a point
i agree with him on like single player
games like i don't think fable is going
to make money unless they put some kind
of microtransaction but i think that
they're willing to
to not necessarily waste the money but
they're willing to invest the money
into something like a fable to make game
pass more diverse so the others games
can make them the money exactly more
attractive yeah because if you keep
these people up in the service you're
gonna make more money in the long run
but the only way to keep them in the
service is to have a diverse library to
make it uh as asses accessible as
possible that's why you're hearing stuff
about the dong
stuff coming on there you have the xbox
series s coming in there so things like
that is what's going to keep game pass
afloat
and i think people need to get on this
hating on this thing hating on that
thing like at the end they what's the
most important thing about this is
if you're getting the games that you
want if you're getting the service at
the price that you want to spend to
that's all that matters that's it it it
like look
i just don't understand why so many
people are interested in game pass it's
just like i really feel like
it's like
okay i was about to say like something
crazy okay i'm not saying it
at the end of the day
the only thing that should be important
is how much you're spending what kind of
content you're getting if you're a
head-to-head fighter and you don't
invest in gay past understand they ain't
nothing in there for you
they they gotta fix that if you are
a racer fan and you're not invested in
game pass what are you doing exactly
there's plenty of stuff in there i mean
that guy sports out the ass in there i
was corrected last week by i don't know
if it was the week before that
to me
game passes only is the value of stuff
that you want in it if they don't have
the games that you want
okay
i don't know why people talk down on
indie so much some of the best indie
games
we need a shirt mate we we what's up acg
we need an indie game
indie games have been some of the best
games i've played moonsh lighters i love
that game it came out when
that game came out when god of war came
out and i enjoyed that more than god of
war
uh star renegades an amazing game in
game past day and day um i think world
west what's that game called
yeah uh yeah i haven't dropped about a
month ago yeah
amazing game in their day and day i get
it it's not everyone everyone's cup of
tea i get it i'm not going to sit there
and say that everyone has to play indie
games but if you're in this chat and you
haven't
when you see an indie game show up and
especially if you see hype
right weird west that's what it's called
if you see hype
at least download it and try it man
what's your story what's the worst thing
i love that's door uh it came after the
game came out i'm talking more about day
and date games it's on my okay
tunic tuning yeah
by the same people keep telling me over
and over again yo you try to you need
try tuning i got it look someone
literally just said tunic when i said it
yeah there's more games than aaa
products i'm not saying aaa products
aren't good they're amazing but we can't
act like
some of these aaa games
my microwave works better than them half
the time and my microwave's a piece of
[ __ ]
so like we gotta admit that sometimes
these games
it doesn't matter what they are it can
make a service more appealing we gotta
admit that and i honestly feel like
people
they're so obsessed
with finding something wrong with game
pass they're not acknowledging what's
right with game pass
exactly is microsoft's first party been
absent this year yes
i hope they fix that now obviously
there's some rumor going around that a
vow is going to come out this year
i would like if i had salt i would show
it like take the whole salt thing that's
where you need to look in that one i
don't think the vowel is coming out this
year now it might maybe maybe the game
was pushed back internally and it was
pretty much done because starfield was
going to come out and they just flipped
them i don't know right i'm not a
developer i don't know what's going on
i do know people at a uh at obsidian but
when it comes to my dead friends i don't
ask them stuff like that because i know
it's going to put them in a weird
situation they're going to feel
uncomfortable because i'm asking about
stuff i shouldn't be asking about so i
never ask about anything like that but
you know
i want to ask you a question
what
do you think that
maybe people are scared
of service industry kind of like the way
the movie industry went to and that's
why people are so
scared for game pass to be extremely
successful
honestly i think it depends on where
it's coming from i
the average gamer no
i believe services is a part of our life
now in 2022
um music
i would
most of us have services like spotify or
itunes i think it's just a part of our
life now you know we talking about
movies yes the movie theater is still a
huge thing but
hell like netflix has what 290 million
subscribers disney plus is 170 million
subscribers that's a lot of people and
yo
i gotta admit it man what's up when i
first heard of disney plus i was like
disney out of they mine
what what kind of content can they
possibly have
they don't slap me in the face yeah
they're killing it man
such a good job like i would honestly
say
for considering they own a lot but when
it comes to reality they don't own a lot
they just own a lot of ips but they
don't really use a lot of them now if
you take away all the like the disney uh
you know uh stuff they make for kids
stuff away they own star wars marvel
they own a lot of stuff but it like it's
stuff that appeals to me they don't own
a lot
but man david like versus the [ __ ] that
i like
yeah they killed him man i watched that
obi-wan they weren't gonna really like
we ain't gonna really spoil anything but
i was like damn i gotta hold on to the
service now man
hold on to this service it's a great two
episodes i wanted you to say they
dropped something in that service that
you enjoy so much you say y'all gotta
hold on to this service
i think that's clearly xbox strategy now
it has been dry in 2022
but that's why you
buy all of these studios you want to put
consistent content in that service and
back to what i was saying um this is our
life now this is what we do you know
we're paying monthly services fees we're
paying
you know streaming that's what that's
what that's the days we're living in so
having a game service
that's
a service a monthly subscription fee to
where i can play games i think that's
great now the people that
may be scared of it
or you know intimidated by it said oh
man i don't want it to hurt the industry
listen there's like maybe those guys are
you know like i don't know like we call
them old heads or you know has an
archaic way of thinking
uh no it's not what it used to be or
it's it's not what it should be then the
then there's the other guys that want
xbox to fail
we know what like who i'm talking about
they want xbox to fail
they want game pass to fail they want
game pass to fail so bad that i seen
some tweets in the past
they want all subscription services to
fail
just to prove their point that gang pass
should be a failure also so
yes there's people that don't want it to
succeed there's people that wanted to
fail but then there's people like us man
i just i enjoy i'm a gamer i'm a real
gamer i enjoy games and game pass
provides me
with games to play and
i still feel game pass is not where it's
going to be
and and i think once everything gets
rolling the the content
drops on a consistent basis
no droughts it's going to be absolutely
incredible see
i do think that uh
we do need
to talk eventually about whether or not
the money that microsoft invests
into the brand can even really be
realistically retrieved in the in the
long long term because damn 68 billion
dollars like that's a lot at the end of
the day like if you want to have a
conversation like that for like uh for
you just just like some kind of i
wouldn't say educational because i want
to [ __ ] about it but you know just a as
some kind of
conversation that's one thing but to go
every week and act like that's the key
component that you talk about
i don't care if they don't make it back
like like look like
first off you got to realize that they
bought activision for multiple reasons
it just wasn't for gaming
they could if they were able to fix
those ips they could easily sell them
that whole company back for more than
they gave i'm not gonna say they ever
gonna do that they're probably never
gonna do that they want those for
multiple reasons but we got to get off
this thing
saying stop being a microsoft's pockets
man stop being in microsoft's pockets
because at the end of the day
i do personally feel like microsoft is
in a very good situation and i like it
because it's going to push
it's going to push playstation a
different direction nintendo ain't never
going to change they're going to be on
the same track they've always been in
but guess what whose fault that is it's
my fault i'm buying pokemon this year i
bought pokemon they're befo the year
before last it's clearly my issues
because we always be buying this stuff
but it's just like if you make good
stuff they will come i've always said
that if you make good games everyone
will come it doesn't matter what it is
uh i i'm under the impression that a
huge portion of all the games budget is
marketing
and you can easily
use marketing to your advantage when
you're out in the market for individual
games anymore you just indiv you just
market game pass and you
yeah and you mentioned like some of the
big games in the service
subscribe to xbox game pass you can play
halo infinity you can play songs or you
can play this you know yeah you're right
about that
now i do feel like
we are the situation where microsoft
does need
to be questioned you know especially
their management skills i'm we're with
you guys
we need a question why is it
you know we just got a mic we just got a
fable thing we could talk about that
here in a second actually that will be
the next topic we talk about because
damn we going through these topics fast
um let me get this super chat in this uh
chat real quick we got a 10 super chat
from flush jackson i love that name man
don't change don't change it you know
why i love it because it's so simple for
me to pronounce i love it
all
walkers are the
subtract for the chips so think of it as
a pizza dough for uh for a pizza and the
chips are the individual toffees
embedded in the dough many chips can be
impended uh
and branded uh
per woofer all right so pretty much it's
like the
is it like like the thermal paste of i
don't know man i don't know yeah i have
no idea i'm not an engineer maybe i need
to get uh
jason ronald on here one time and
explain to me yes i have no idea
uh then we got a 20 month super chat
from viper xt uh 20 month uh message
they want to separate the series s and
the series x sales but quick to come uh
to combine the playstation plus tiers
all together oh
he's absolutely right somebody just
didn't did that to me
that was a pretty good
that was pretty good man that was dude
he's right about that and somebody just
did that to me on twitter they were
talking trash and say yo look at
playstation sales or you know like
playstation plus and they're kind of
adding them all together
that's funny so we got we got 80 likes
up in here man we got 330 people almost
watching i appreciate you guys for
coming through man like you know i i
will admit i've had a really really
rough week and i and i did look forward
to coming here and just talking it up
because like iop love iop
but sometimes i'm selfish man i want to
talk and when you get wait you see and
and iops of way more structured podcasts
than this sometimes i can't talk and i
can make it
that's why i interrupt so much
in case you guys ain't noticed i haven't
interrupted as much as i nearly has it
done because i do take input i see
people say yo addict stop interrupting
i'm like damn
did it again got a two dollar super job
from kendrick starr what's up dirt
didn't know you was was here what's up
addict what's up kendrick what up
kendrick what's up brother how you doing
man
so you know i'm here uh addicts world
yeah i'm i'm the i'm the man oh yeah i'm
the sheriff i can kick you out if i want
to
people got mad because i used to say
that i'm the sheriff of the addicts
world and i can kick you out if i want
to i don't know man i don't know all
right so let's talk about this fable
thing i didn't put this in here but
let's talk about this did you see how
supposedly fabled's world has been
downside due to technical issues or
something like that
yeah something with scope
um yeah uh i guess uh gas said that he
heard
that fable
was was downsized and like they were
having issues with the forza tech engine
or something like that
i was actually told well actually maybe
i shouldn't say that
never mind i wasn't told nothing all
right so
look
at the end of the day
people need to realize this happens in
every
artwork known to man
uh the same people saying yo there's
something wrong they're they're they're
down saying size of the same people
buying the the special version of the
marvels that comes with the deleted
scenes
where you think those deleted scenes
came from dirk
right they were cut from the game
yeah they filmed them did they decide
i've never no it's not even just filming
i've heard of scenarios where people
work for weeks
on story your relative content for these
like tv shows and stuff and it's all cut
weeks down the drain back to the future
uh uh like uh you know like back to your
future story i know you heard about that
story right
now you know how eric stouts was marty
mcfly
they did two weeks of work and the
director was like he's not the guy
[Laughter]
so they had cuz they wanted michael j
fox initially he couldn't do it they got
another guy to do it they filmed two
weeks and they said you know what
he's not the guy they say it isn't gonna
work and they
made deals to get michael j fox and
obviously that was the right move
all right so pretty much what happened
is you know
uh a developer came out amory miss
sparkles i believe her name she's a
senior
she's a senior producer at fable at
playground games
she said i wanted to clear something up
about scoping it is a normal necessary
and healthy part of a game development i
can guarantee you that every triple a
game you've ever played will have gone
through scoping regularly during
development it's intentional is to make
sure the team are focused under one
clear vision and can get it made in time
without killing it uh themselves games
that haven't been sculpt correctly often
have delays and crunch but we
should be uh aiming to avoid what uh
both whenever whenever possible look
uh we've had developers such as undead
labs on here they said they cut stuff in
the game we just saw rumors going on
that uh
um
what's it called that star field had
stuck cut from the game it's it's
it is natural it happens all the time
how many times do you see people going
through the game code of a game and they
find stuff that was cut from the game
but it wasn't took out of the game right
like we saw bosses that was an elden
ring that was never in the game because
they will go all the way up to the point
where it's in the game and then realize
they can't make it work and then they
and then they're like should we take
weeks to take this out because sometimes
this whole regions
that just aren't working and they take
it out this is normal
i get it people are are are
i feel like just this is just me dirt
tell me if i'm bugging hustle ain't here
so you won't have to be the dude that
tells me he's attic buggin
okay i feel like there's a witch hunt
i feel like
if you can even remotely make something
where you could put put it in a in a
slight toss to the fact that maybe
microsoft isn't managing a studio
correctly you're doing it in a hall
yeah and i feel like that's going on
here because to me
we so there's no reason to think that
this studio isn't capable of making gank
good games sure just about to say that
they've made forza and i get it it's a
completely and i'm special with you guys
i'm like yo
i don't know about this they making
cause fable is important to me
extremely important to me i played favor
one fable two fabled three hell i even
played that stupid ass connect game
i don't even like that in that game
i i've played all of these games
multiple times
it i just
i want it to be good but at the same
time
i can't say that a studio that has
nothing but shown quality can at least
make a solid game as a fable french keep
in mind thank you that back in the day
before all this happened there's huge
rumors going around that was pretty much
saying
that playground games didn't want like
that they didn't want to be bought
and the only reason that they agreed to
be bought was because they
pitched them an idea for a game that
they owned
and people assumed it was fatal
and then microsoft bought them now i'm
not saying that's exactly what happened
i'm not saying that
but i am saying that
they bought
them
i don't think it was for the forza
horizon franchise they've been making
them for for like a decade right why
would you buy a studio make it why would
you buy a student already making the
games you want there ain't no issues
there microsoft owns the ip
but they bought them when they started
making fable because i feel like
microsoft
is trusting fable and i've been told
that there is like there's like halo
money behind fable
like this isn't something cheap that
they do this is
this isn't something that is going to be
like a very low budget this has money
behind it now is it going to be as much
as they put in favor i don't i mean hey
i don't know but i have been told that
it's got a lot of money going behind
this franchise
i can believe that we got a two dollar
super chat from flame
for example destiny cut 98 of his
content
oh my god you guys have guys have
serious issues with fable well no flame
does we got a two dollar superstar from
luke skywalker i love that god of war
ragnarok is cut [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god king uh
you are here and you're not even here
that's funny man we got a five dollar
super draft from pixel bit g remind
people that four entire worlds were cut
from god of war ragnarok started as dlc
and was extended also we know pre e3
xbox gets hate uh gets hated on yearly i
agree with you to a point i don't think
i don't here's the thing i think even
dirk would agree that
all the year
that xbox one with the xbox series x was
coming out and a lot of the year after
that
there was nothing but positivity on xbox
there's negative stuff with xbox so they
they rightfully get the criticism
right uh just like playstation they'll
get the criticism that they do
people will get smoke when they do
things wrong
but microsoft has been doing a lot of
things wrong lately and it's not
necessarily stuff that's in their
control uh when you buy all these
studios and
i'm not saying that they didn't know how
to manage studios but i'm saying that
they managed such a small amount
originally and then you go from managing
four or five studios to imagining like
like 24 right now about to be 30
something and keep in mind how long of
like like a two or three year distance
that they owned all these
yeah like that's so long that's a very
short amount of time to take this amount
of teams under your wing and i'm not
saying that
microsoft's completely 100 squeaky clean
i'm not saying that because i do think
that they got their issues man i feel
like you know everybody's flawless
what's going on three four three that's
a hundred percent microsoft's fault
because
they've let them drop the ball on halo
multiple times and i'm not saying that
infinite was a drop the ball moment i
felt like it did a lot of things right
but
in hindsight
maybe they should have just bit the
bullet and delayed it again
i don't know but you know it is what it
is let's get these super chats real
quick and we'll continue
with this
oh no okay we already got them all right
so you got them yep when it comes to
fable man
it's like i said i want this game to be
better and i understand where people are
coming from
if it was a bad studio not necessarily a
bad studio studio that hasn't really
shown that they can make very high
quality games i would be right there
with you guys but can we see gameplay
first before we
go with crazy
well well you know attic i um
you mentioned it
see
when there is a trust factor with the
studio you just
trust them you know like
that's like with you you know like with
your credit
when they pour laura at his credit and
they say oh man you've paid all your
bills on time for years mr addict
what do you want
it's a trust thing right your credit
shows that they can trust you because in
the past you have done the right thing
you've paid all your bills on time
so when you look at playground games yes
i know they've only made forza horizon
games
but each and every one of those games
have been absolutely incredible so
i trust them until they prove otherwise
until they show me otherwise
right yes i know they're going from a
racing genre to
role playing game but i trust them
so
whatever happened whatever is happening
okay
okay i don't
i'm not behind the scenes i'm a guy that
likes to eat i'm not really the guy that
likes to cook so whatever the chefs are
doing
i trust them to make sure the food is
good now when it
it's not cooked right it's burning on
this side burning inside
the
the noodles feel like dough then we go
on we go into the kitchen we're going to
the kitchen with this bad food and
demanding a refund but exactly you guys
want to complain
before you even get in the restaurant
bam
it's just like exactly
it's like i said exactly complain when
it makes sense microsoft seems to have
some issues with management there's been
multiple studios with issues that's
that's valid
playstation seems to feel like they can
do whatever they want with these likes
and relatively anti-consumer moves i
know people feel like people use that
word too much i digress we're not going
to go into that
that's worth criticism but saying
playground games is cutting content when
every other studio does that
and then saying that's an issue when we
ain't even seen anything on but cgi
cutscene i don't think that's an issue i
think people need to relax
i think you already said it it's a it's
a witch hunt
like you said
because you know this year they they've
had some public stories like regardless
of issues with their development teams a
couple of development teams and
this one oh look it's happening again
look at xbox it's happening again but
like you said those guys didn't even
take time to actually do their research
and i'm glad that this developer came
out to say yo this happens in every
triple-a game
yeah but it is what it is man so you
know we ain't gonna go too much into
that like i said
i get it
yeah this is just another story
of some negative stuff with microsoft
first off i don't think it's a negative
story i think it's just something that
happens what's funny is i've been told
that sometimes publishers have to keep
developers like in a realistic mindset
because if you let a developer and give
him money and never you know yo we got
to do this we got to do this they will
keep developing because
a lot of developers are like they want
everything perfect
they they they want to sh to to you know
stretch that that muscle that creative
muscle constantly and sometimes
what you get
versus
how much long it took doesn't make sense
and a developer nine times out of ten yo
but it'll be lit we gotta do it we gotta
do it
we gotta do it but then there's the
money side of it's like yo but you know
how how long is that going to take
how much money we're going to have to
put into it like there's got to be a
little bit of give and take when it
comes to it i think faye was going to do
fine i don't think fable is is going to
be issues now when we see the the
gameplay or any form of gameplay and it
looks bad
then you're gonna hear me going here be
like man
dirt they fell man they fell
they let us down no but i think you'll
be fine though
playground game if they're
they're absolutely incredible so i'm
i was playing forza horizon 5 the other
day
and that's that's one of those games
where you just
put down a controller for a second and
say damn
this game looks incredible you know like
the trees were blowing it was about to
rain
it looked incredible so i'm pretty sure
playing around games are going to make
sure fable was a quality
yeah and then you know who i don't even
know faye was even on that engine have
they ever came out officially and said
what engine there no they didn't maybe
that's just the assumption i'm not sure
all right so let's go ahead and move on
man let's move on to the
uh to the prime example of the evening
well let me do it like the the ufc thing
welcome to them do they say welcome i
can't remember it's been so long like
welcome to the main event of the evening
in the left corner is the state of play
predictions and the right corner is dirt
griggity in in lourdes
so there we go we okay keep in mind the
state of play is tomorrow at like 6
pm-ish i don't know
we will be doing a live reaction to it
uh i actually tried to do something else
but king was like
but addict i want to do it man you know
how king wants to do it
damn i was all right king we'll do it
man we'll do it i got you king i got you
so
i'm going to be live stream with cog i
don't know if salve will be there so
i've got like nine jobs
uh so you know hopefully he can make it
i don't know
but the thing is when it comes down to
it is
this is only third party stuff and the
way that they've hyped this up
people say oh it's third party addict so
i think it's it's it's final fantasy 16.
i've seen people throw personas six out
like
i feel like they're going to put that
for the playstation showcase
yeah why this is a state of play right
this is a state of play
okay
what is your
expectations when it comes to this not
your predictions what you expect
well since they already mentioned it
definitely a lot of psvr2 stuff they
already showed they already said they're
going to show that horizon game on psvr
2. um you know
i think you're on to something right
there because people that's
automatically assuming they say
third-party partners they're going to
show street fighter 6 or or final
fantasy 16 and like you said
unless final fantasy 16 is coming out in
two months they're probably going to
wait until the playstation showcase to
show a game that big state of plays are
usually you know smaller shows like the
show's under 30 minutes they're not
going to show too much
right um
so i'm thinking when it comes to
third-party partners
maybe there's some multiplex that sony
has marketing deals
maybe maybe a couple of indies
um if they do show final fantasy 16 or
something like that i would be surprised
people saying death stranding i saw that
throwing out there too that's right
anyone too yeah
nah
nah
this is a state of play y'all it's not
their showcase i
i'm expecting like you said addict i'm
expecting the big games being shown at
that showcase whenever it is in
september i know last two years it was
in september so yeah um
i don't know 30 minutes bro what can
they do much in 30 minutes is a short
time yeah they're going to show us
20 minutes of final fantasy 16 and
10 minutes of vr that's what we're gonna
see
got a five dollar super chat from alvin
uh final fantasy vii
uh remake and persona 5 has been taken
off the playstation console exclusive
list on the playstation site grain
assault but it's curious i didn't know
that i didn't know i've heard of yeah i
read that earlier plays persona 5 is no
longer now is
i know persona 5 has royale now so i'm
kind of curious did they take it off
that and put it on the royale one
or is it off both
i don't know final fantasy 7 remake it's
on pc so it's not really exclusive
but do they actually physically say
console exclusive or just exclusive
cool i don't remember i don't know alvin
you you know feel free to uh
to comment i'm just under the
assumption is never coming to xbox
that's just i'm thinking you know it's
not coming to xbox but i hope i'm wrong
you know be crazy if we actually get a
um
if we get a final fantasy and a persona
announcement at this e3
that'd be cool
yo you guys want to hear me flip out let
le okay okay okay i know this probably
clap
if you guys want me to see me truly flip
out let a final fantasy 7 remake
be announced at game pass
uh not even game pass xbox in general
i'll be okay with and then let persona
come out for xbox and then let a fable
gameplay show in the same e3
they will never be another you'll never
hear me [ __ ] ever again
that one so those three things that's
what you need those three things those
three things
is better than the year microsoft then
sony announced final fantasy 7.
no no no
okay let me let me rephrase that let me
2015 was that 2014 yeah let me rephrase
that
fable got to look good
and faithful look bad
okay then we're having a conversation
okay then we have a conversation i do
feel like we need personal okay but
okay now let's instead of your
expectations what is some of your
predictions
hmm
okay um
some of my predictions i think that
uh they're not gonna show call of duty
oh man
maybe they
were they so for spoken again
um
no oh yeah yeah
i think it's gonna be right there with
um how i feel about uh
about death loop when it was coming out
i ended up loving death loop and i get
made fun of by a lot of the people uh
that i'm cool with and a lot of my
friends in the industry because
for some reason i love death loop and
everyone around me hated it really yeah
i love playing game i love that i can't
play it now i'd stop but i can play it
now but i'll probably wait till they
come to the next spot yeah at this point
you should just cuz i you know i uh
prefer achievements you know what if we
do see a death fluke trailer at the e3
maybe you know they might do that they
might do it and announce it it's coming
this whatever september
uh yeah but i know i don't my
predictions i'm sorry to let you down
lord addict but i don't know
i don't know what the hell they don't
show
only the psvr
to they already announced that
okay maybe they will show final fantasy
16 but i'm more in the
lines of i think they will wait for it
to be a bigger show but then again even
though this is a state of play this is
close to
xbox big show we have summer game fest
coming up so maybe they will show final
fantasy 16 so that's what i'm going with
they're gonna show final fantasy 16.
show some gameplay from final fantasy
16.
oh that that that's cool like all i want
is good games man i feel like death loop
was a great game man
you know i can't wait to play it bro i
love arcane games i i love arkansas
yeah i felt like dishonored
look it didn't have the greatest story i
had a cool story i feel like this owner
had a better universe and i felt like
they could have made death loop in the
dishonored universe if they would have
just made a couple slight changes
yeah yeah
what happened to your multi-week xbox
showcase predictions uh addict um
star phil got delayed i don't want to
talk about him
hey i feel hey you know what i say
that's a good point yeah you gotta delay
now i might have something next week you
know something right before the show
we're on a wednesday they would be on a
sunday you know i might have some uh
some people right on before the show
i don't know though man i don't know
we'll see let's see
here's why i feel about this i feel like
this makes me kind of think now that god
of war is definitely getting delayed
really because like how are you going to
come out in june
and say yo we doing something else on
something else
um everyone's looking forward to god of
war
but you doing a state of play on
something else that's not god award
wait a minute hold on wait a minute alec
you got me thinking it is june
it's june 1st today
tomorrow wait a minute that is something
so you're saying because they're
dropping this state of play in june
first and they're and and they have
already announced no first party stuff
so you're saying
if you were dropping god award this year
they would probably they should be
announcing the date soon right
[Music]
unless they have a teaser at the end of
this showing another state of play
but to me once again
why do that when you could have the
teaser
on a youtube video going into this
right i mean i guess they could
theoretically give it to what's his name
uh the summer game show
but it's just like
they've never really done that are they
gonna
i've never i can't
i'm probably wrong so i'm chat you're
gonna tell me i'm wrong i know
put a time in there where playstation
said someone else can have something as
big as god of war's release date
because i don't think i could i don't
think i can give you a time i really can
i don't know one time that that's
happened
and
they've always been they've been very
big on giving an entire
state of
play to something like that and part of
me just feels like
if they would have done that they would
have done it by now like what what are
they waiting for
what what what
are they going to do in like july
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good point man that's a
good point but i do remember them
with god of war 2018
dropping the release date like on
twitter and it was like maybe february
and it came out in april
unless i'm wrong but i do remember
something like that so maybe they'll do
that like drop a release date in
august and the game drops in september i
don't know maybe you know but maybe
that's just me
i just want i i just i want a good god
of war keep in mind this is the last god
of war as well uh not like as ever but
this is the god war that concludes
uh this series there's no trilogy this
is it and then right i assume he's gonna
go to egypt and mess all them up next i
don't know that'd be cool i ain't going
to lie man i'll be i'm gonna put that
i'm with that go over there and do some
i just want i'm a little skeptical a
little feared on my end that it's gonna
be hard to connect all the dots that
needs to be connected in this game
i'm not saying they can't do it
because saint monica is a very good
studio i will say that there's a new
lead there uh you know corey barlow's
doing something else he's not yeah he's
not working on this god of war he's
doing something else with saint monica
so i'm kind of curious
you know can we give the same type of
energy to 2018
going into this one that we gave 2018
when the same person didn't make 2018.
i don't know like i personally feel like
it's up in the air i'm not gonna say
it's not gonna be a bad game
confident it's gonna be a very well
received game
yeah but i don't think you're gonna get
the same
the same feedback you got from 2018.
you don't think so the reason i don't
think that's because you can only switch
[ __ ] up one time
you can only do it once now i don't
think
you can't do it again so soon you know
um they did it with zelda zelda guy game
of the year switch shut up completely
got it
did it with god of war went from
whatever it was to this switch it up
drastically got it
elden ring just did it with the from
software formula
and they're arguably going to get game
of the year
you don't have that sign of that type of
effect
like you had it the first time you did
it
and i don't think they're going to have
it this time i think they're gonna it's
gonna be received well because the game
is good
right but as far as the game gets the
kind of critical success that the
original one got i don't think that's
happening because you can't recapture
something that happened in 2018 when
they switched up the the type of formula
that god of war
it was
i honestly feel like
it changed the industry i really do
in 2018 people was looking at that god
of war formula and they were looking at
their games it's like if they change it
up why can't we
right and you know i'm not saying that's
how zelda happened or anything like that
zelda is probably going to happen
regardless but i'm saying that that
expired a lot of developers to their
franchises that's been stagnant for a
while
let's just flip it up on its back
and i don't know if they're going to get
that again and
so i feel like because of this because
the state of play
i don't know if we can realistically see
a god of war
this year when we're in june
they know people want to see something
god of war related
and they're showing us vr
let me repeat that
we're in june
which is iconically in the gaming world
is the e3 time e3 is not here but people
still expect that kind of news there's
there's there's a reason that jeff
keeley and xbox and sega are all doing
stuff at the beginning of june
but so but sony shows up yeah we got
this vr stuff for you
we we don't we got some third parties
therefore
like maybe
i'm wrong
and they show final fantasy 16 here
because the other big game that god's
got a war and they give that to jeff
keeley it's possibility right but to me
they've never done that not one time
god of war was showing on their stuff
horizon was sewn on their stuff death
straining
that might have been shown somewhere
else i don't know
the first time they showed their
stranded was that e3 sony e3 i believe
it was 2015. goes to sashima their stuff
release dates to all these games their
stuff
i don't remember the last time they
might show little game players somewhere
else but they never show
original stuff like in a release date or
you know an announcement they don't do
that microsoft does that and i [ __ ] at
them every year for doing it because
there's a reason when my when sony has
their big showcases it's an event
everyone loves it everyone's there
everyone's watching that's because we
know
their stuff is there
and i feel like the past few years
microsoft has kind of dropped the ball
and i'm not saying
they haven't dropped it for good reasons
they were coming from a really bad
generation
people weren't trying to watch their
content like that
and so i could understand especially
inside xbox kind of like soured the bowl
a little bit too where people
you know had unrealistic expectations
for stuff like gamepad for for inside
xbox so i can understand that but when
you go out there and you just had an xo
i think it was the year of xo or the
year of e3 and yeah you have a decent
showing not amazing but decent and then
three or four months later you showed
the xbox series x and hellblade when
that could have easily been shot at your
show
and it would have made your show way
better than it was i get it i do think
it was the right move i do but i can't
say i understand but i disagree
yeah i see what you're saying
you know this is something i haven't
thought about though because i was kind
of under the impression at first i was
like yeah god award will probably be
delayed to 2023 then i said nah
i think it's going to come out this year
but you just brought up some great
points
some great points
interesting make me think
you're making me think right now sir
i think to me the biggest question is
when
you know
when that's the biggest question when
we don't know when man we we don't know
when these games come out we don't know
none of that um you know but i do think
like i said you know we're having uh
this day to play tomorrow are going to
be reacting with it on on this channel
next week
uh i might try to bring like acg or
someone if they're if they're if they're
not busy uh you know just chat it up on
you know our final expectations going
into the show
uh you know people have been asking me
to get acg on the show a few times
uh i keep trying to tell them like he's
a busy dude but i'll try you know i i'll
hit him up see if he's see if he's busy
you know what's funny is uh because i've
been doing a lot of content with my girl
so acg followed her
and uh she was like oh my god acg
followed me on twitter i'm like oh jesus
man she got so excited and you know that
that that that that lit me up to man it
was like you know just to see her
excited because she she's never really
been on social media like that so it's
something like a big personality
followed her it just it it as bad as it
sounded made her feel important for a
second you know what i'm saying so it is
nice to see that like that joy in her
eyes when she saw that
she's had a pretty [ __ ] that's cool man
that's good so we got a two dollar super
chat from paula cooper if they don't
show god of war tomorrow it won't come
out to 2022. that's not necessarily true
but i agree with you i would say if they
don't show tomorrow it drops another 20
it goes to like i would say 60 60 40.
uh and then they don't show in a month
it goes to like 30 70.
right i see what you're saying
like so the longer that it goes the
lower that percentage is right because
at this point when are they going to do
it
right right yeah it's june
hey man hey man you know paula cooper is
the homie yo what's up bro thanks for
stopping by man yeah i appreciate it
people like having you on here man
well i i i love him right hey man my boy
[ __ ] q
he said yeah what's up man thanks for
stopping by man
all right so you know i think we're
gonna go ahead and uh close this out man
we had 342 people in here right now i
definitely hit that like button you guys
man let's get that done
200 likes by the end of the show you
guys have been showing up here at
harcourt the past couple months man i
really appreciate it you know that this
addict show you say i used to do it like
a like as a oh i'll do it when i do it
you know how like you start the
podcasting life and he was like yo i do
it like once or twice a month and then
you feel like you got to be a little bit
more serious so you do it like two times
a month then you feel like damn i'm not
taking it serious serious yeah so then
you start doing weekly you got a two
dollar superstar from yeah baby farvey
fargo
i don't know
blessed up fellas i see you gregory uh
what's up bro yeah you keep going and
going and now i'm doing it every week
and i feel like people
are starting to uh consistency is the
key bro yeah people
people don't realize how hard it is to
do youtube too
yeah it's not easy man podcasting's a
little easier than youtube but people
feel like podcasting's easy it's not
last night gotta get people
to that you vibe with good you got to
get people that you ain't gonna that
that you know
you can push
but they're not going to go over the
board like they're not going to like
flip the hell out
exactly like sometimes you know me and
like people don't like jade up i get it
he's really crazy on twitter but i love
jw he's one of my close friends and you
know i know if i get him on a show i
could push that dude to the very edge
the very edge like he can literally
here's the edge here's him and i know
that if i could literally push him again
and he starts going like this and i know
he's not gonna like come back out with
the punch you know what i'm saying like
he knows his jokes and he knows i'm not
gonna like take it serious but i
appreciate it for coming through you
know dirk gregory you got anything going
on man what you got going on uh you know
yeah man uh my boy sean 786 we're
streaming the state of play tomorrow on
his channel at six o'clock p.m eastern
time stop and check it out and yeah
ma'am just you know trying to do content
on my youtube channel uh you know we
have our podcast on monday evenings at 6
30 p.m
called weebly green xbox podcast and
yeah we have a lot of fun over there so
stop by and check it out man put the
link in the chat
and now just like i said i appreciate
her for coming through um oh no problem
man it's been a good thing i appreciate
you for coming through i asked him a
couple days ago thank god i asked him
yeah
see it's a little better if you give me
a heads up you know i can uh you know if
i have something to do if it's not too
important you know yeah i can be here i
usually like sometimes you know are you
trying to get people out here like an
hour and a half to two hours try to that
sweet spot and if it is two hours it's
like not a couple it's a couple minutes
over two hours uh because i know you
know
i ain't trying to have another two three
hour show i do one a week
and i do i podcast enough on sunday that
some of you podcasts two or three
podcasts a week
yeah
it's kind of funny yeah so dirk put his
channel in there man go over there and
subscribe to the man he's a good person
uh you guys know hustle go subscribe to
him go over there on twitter uh wish he
hustle a happy birthday not happy
birthday
wish him
hope he feels better man
oh you just giving his birthday today
happy
it's everyone's birthday dirt griggity
birthday it's my birthday it's
everyone's birthday
next week i'll probably try to have
another little prediction show like i
said try to get more oh yeah people let
me say this uh addy did a prediction
show was it like two or three weeks ago
like maybe a month now right yeah closer
to him i totally love the way he he did
the prediction show he separated he
didn't let people go on a 20-minute rant
about everything they thought was going
to be at the show he separated the you
know yo man what games you think is not
going to be there what games will
surprise you and i loved it so uh you
know we have our petition show
monday on my channel and i hope that it
don't matter that i borrow his you
know can you can steal the whole thing
man yeah it was it was fire man so i
said damn that's pretty dope that's the
way he did i love the way he did that so
yeah because sometimes i hate on
prediction shows people just go on a
20-minute rant then you go to the next
person they go on a 20-minute rant
they're separated let's have a little
fun with it so thanks for that yeah i
got a little bit of that format from uh
cog how he does them i took a couple of
things like like to see uh what you
don't want to see there and i need yes i
believe that
we're coming through we're gonna be here
next week a hustle be back next week uh
you know i don't know of dirt yeah
dirt's kind of like my third
wingman whatever he can make it uh so
you know whenever he we we are still
working on the the xbox show uh would
probably have a
promotion thing out friday saturday tell
them who the guests are i got two of
them one of them confirmed
uh but i'm still working on the rest uh
i got to make the the prediction uh
promotion which takes like eight nine
hours because it's ridiculous
and then i'm sure that podcast is gonna
be long as hell too
uh so definitely iop this sunday
prediction show xbox you guys know how
we do we we go above and beyond for that
show
uh you know we were supposed to have a
playstation an xbox one but
kind of grabbed the playstation one by
the neck
and i was like we can do you later
because
to me it made no sense to do a
playstation show
when there's no show announced yet right
so when the playstation show is
announced
most likely the sunday before that show
we will have one of that now you guys
could tag in the comments section on
playstation juice to invite to that
because i don't know anyone so
you know appreciate uh you know we'll
probably have like jabari in them back
on uh because we we do try to have some
playstation show but a lot of them are
like i wouldn't say toxic but we don't i
see eye on content you know what i'm
saying like so we we have to be a little
bit uh picky on that because uh you know
we do want everyone to enjoy it and if
we go down too many rants on one way or
the other it gets gets chaotic but i
appreciate we're coming through we're
gonna go ahead and close out the show
get barry
and blaze at it we'll see about that i
like blaze blade's good dude but i
appreciate every coming through we're
gonna call it quits man